[Music]
okay good afternoon everyone nice to see
you all here let's get good let's get
rolling
by the way so annotating data the right
way a little bit about myself I'm a data
scientist and developer at booking.com
I've been coding professionally for the
last 15 years or so and for the last
eight years I've been working with
Python on machine learning and NLP
problems and today we're going to talk a
little bit about annotations and how to
do them right so I hope to convince you
that you should think carefully how you
start annotation project and how you
create it then how you scale it farther
internally within your company with
internal rotators but also externally
with Musante with math notation services
and in addition we will talk about the
common case of having unbalanced data
and how to handle this using active
learning so the problem the setting that
we will use in order to provide examples
will be the setting of a chat bot that
we have at booking.com
you can try it facebook messenger at
booking calm and try to book a room with
us and in this chat bot we are trying
for one of the problems we have is that
users might ask us questions like is
this hotel has free cancellation policy
and you would like to identify the topic
and of course provide the right
information for the users so they can
book with confidence so basically our
setting is text settings and it's text
classification I would like to stress
that this kind of this kind of
guidelines are applicable not only to
text but also for images videos medical
records whatever you need whatever data
that you take humans to label and humans
have varying opinions and you should
probably take this into account when
you're doing annotation party
come and join us everybody yeah so just
quickly repeat that the setting is text
chat bot but this guidelines are not
applicable only to text and we will
start right away with understanding the
first step in an annotation project is
deciding whether we should really do
this it's very expensive to annotate it
takes a lot of human time to just go on
and label each example and you need to
think whether you have cheaper options
that you can utilize for example
external data sources or unsupervised
learning some kind of heuristics maybe
you can get like 70% accuracy on
whatever problem that you need to tackle
and that 70% accuracy is good enough for
your product and you should push it to
your customers either way and see how
they interact with this with this
machine learning model or even like
simple regular expression model and then
you will learn a lot more whether you
need or not better performance or
accuracy so think about this also many
times you can deduce the label from the
user's behavior so if you have a ranking
problem and you recommend some item if
the user want this item then it's a
positive level if they don't use this
don't want this item they didn't bought
it then it's a positive then it's a
negative level and you can you can
deduce it without annotating however in
many cases we do need to we do need to
annotate sometimes the problem is very
specific or complex like in our cases we
have a lot of different types of
information we would like to provide
users with and there is no external data
source also we have a very weak feedback
loop so someone might ask you ask us
basically if the hotel is wheelchair
accessible and we would answer I'm sorry
but it's not and then the user would not
book it doesn't mean that we didn't get
the label right it just means that this
hotel does not suit the user so we can't
really deduce it and the bonus of
annotating anyway
is that you get in domain quality data
for your product and usually when you
think what should I invest my timing
getting more in domain quality data or
having a better larger neural network
more complex model domain database it by
far so that's a bonus of annotating so
we decided to annotate but the first
thing we need to do is explore our data
maybe you think you know like what kind
of labels you need but until you get a
real feel for the data you might change
your mind so use some kind of a flexible
tool I use Google Spreadsheets a lot for
this but whatever thing that works for
you is also fine and try to kind of
annotate the different examples that you
see try to change the labels as you go
you might think that one category is
very dominant but when you look at the
data you see that it's not that common
or another category which you didn't
think is exists at all seems to be seems
to be very dominant in the data so
change the labels try to explore your
data understand what kind of categories
or labels you need and then create some
kind of initial guidelines of what are
the categories that you need after you
create your categories you need to
define the labels very specifically and
I would would like to really explain why
clear boundaries are crucial for you
because let's take this example now
understand Paquito in class let's assume
that your that your task is
understanding whether this this sentence
is in English or not in English what
would you do with that who would say
this is English please raise your hands
okay interesting
I would I would think it's still English
someone tried to talk English with us
without much success but the different
views cause the data to be noisy if help
of the annotators will be will use one
label and the other health will use
another label then the data set would be
very
noisy it will be very hard to generalize
this data and your machine learning
performance would be suboptimal
so try to write down the guidelines as
you go whenever you see an example like
this which you need a minute to to think
about copy it to your guidelines and
elaborate why you choose one label or
the other try to really set clear
boundaries in order to get a real clean
data there is no other way in addition
your labels should reflect whatever
actions you're going to take in your
product so for example let's assume that
we have a different action for showing
room facilities and different action for
showing hotel facilities like swimming
pool and we don't want to show both to
the user it's a lot of data we just want
to show one of them depending of the
question of the user so I will use
different label for each kind of
sentence either it's a question about
two facilities or a question about hotel
facilities I would not use some kind of
abstract category like facilities
because then I will have to insert
another model or another decision in
between which makes all my evaluation
all my testing very very indirect so I
don't know if my mother is good because
I have another thing that needs to
decide after my mother decides what is
the label so try to stick to your
actions when you're annotating and try
to stick to your near future near-term
goals in the product so let's assume we
have a topic of transportation a lot of
people asking us how do you get from the
hotel to the airport is there is a metro
station nearby the hotel that's a lot of
good questions but maybe I don't have
the data right now to answer these kind
of questions so I don't need to annotate
them like rigorously this is the label
of walking distance and this is the
label of airport transportation and so
forth I will just get a big bucket
category of transportation put
everything there if the user
asks about it I will say well we do not
support it right now but do not waste
the brain power of your annotators to
really do this and get some kind of
perfect Labor's for things you're not
going to use right now probably when
you'll get the data and super
transportation you will have different
ideas about what kind of categories you
need and you will need to revisit and
change the annotations anyway so don't
waste your time and others time on this
ok so right now we kind of finished the
first the first quarter of the
presentation understanding whether we
should start an annotation project
exploring the data creating some action
minded annotation scheme and this at
this stage you might have already a few
hundred examples annotated by you
because you were working on the data and
it might be a good time to stop because
maybe you can chain some kind of model
which has etiquette performance and it
can be pushed to users and and see how
it affects them and if it helps them at
all and you might be surprised but
that's an important thing to do you do
not always need to strive to get the
best accuracy just before you push it to
the customers try to use the model in
production as soon as possible so
possibly there is no need to continue
but if you do want to continue let's
have a short intermission on annotation
tools and how to construct them so in
the past at listen in the linguistic
community annotation tools were horrible
I'm sorry if someone I've ever worked in
right which is the screenshot but you
need to understand very thoroughly and
with sticks in order to annotate part of
speech tagging dependency person
constituency parsing lemmas everything
each such sentence took a lot of time to
annotate a lot of training and it was
very hard to change later on this kind
of annotation is really not scalable
very easily I would advise you to use
simpler tasks and one annotation at a
time
so the screenshot here is coming from a
tool called prodigy you can see in the
middle the text that we need to annotate
and then on the title the label of a
defeated artificial intelligence and the
annotator basically has only three
options either accept the labor this is
correct or rejected the label does not
fit the text or ignore it skip it
because of any reason and that's kind
the that's kind of the whole decision
that the analyzer should do and that's
what and this is what you should strive
for you should strive to have simpler
tests which the annotator can do one
after after another quickly in order to
do this you will have a lot of different
annotation tests which cover you because
you might have a lot of and a lot of
things you would like to annotate so you
need flexible tools prodigy for example
provides you with a lot of different UI
components like labeling or part of
speech tagging image labeling etc and
database connections so you can write
your you can write your data and all you
need to do is just to define the word to
get the data from how to iterate over it
and that's all so use this flexible
tools do not reinvent the wheel and
create your own UI your own database
connection your own logic for annotation
there are tools out there prodigy is a
paid tool I would not say it's worth
every penny because I don't know how
many pennies you have in your pocket but
it's worth quite a lot so try this you
can also change the kana which is a open
source tool or even Google Spreadsheets
it's a flexible UI it's a familiar UI it
might be suitable for your needs okay so
we have a tool we have guidelines we
think everything is great now we want to
test that what we think are the
guidelines are really what any other
would think is correct and in this case
we need to check the agreement with a
colleague so take a teammate annotate
the same logs the same examples as
you're she annotate and then for example
put it on a heat map you can see very
clearly that the diagonal are the
examples that we both agree on so there
are numbers there and the color also
indicates the number so we can see we
have a pretty nice agreement but we can
also see that there are a little bit
lighter colors for some columns and rows
which means disagreements on different
Labor's between me and the other
annotator so you should take this
example this discuss it I understand
what was confusing in the guidelines
because you wrote them for yourself for
yourselves and many times it's not very
understandable by others so see if this
is a see what what is confusing in the
guidelines change them and then iterate
try take another teammate annotated with
him or her and see that your agreement
rate goes up so this is a visual way to
check a government where there is of
course the mathematical way which we all
should shine and use so an agreement
score is very basic it's just how many
examples we agreed upon out of the total
number of examples and it should be high
at least 80% but many times and for many
tasks you need a different more
sophisticated metric for example let's
assume you have 90% of your data labeled
zero and 10% of your data labeled one I
could just annotate everything with zero
and probably get to 90% agreement right
which is not what we want so things like
CAPA score unable to take into account
like the prior distribution of labor's
and kind of normalized argument rate
according to them you might have a
different problem and in these cases you
might you might need different metrics
so you have coins Kappa slices and a
full handbook of integrator reliability
to read and and I just so we iterated
and our guidelines are perfect and
everybody understands is the same now we
need to scale
so at first the best option in my view
to scale is to use internal annotators
they know your world they know your
domain they're part of your company so
you can talk with them and introduce
them to your world to your product to
the problem that you're trying to solve
like what is what are these annotations
going to be used for it will help them
annotate then of course you need to
check the agreement with them between
themselves and also the agreement
between you and them and if you are
satisfied they can start working and
really create creating a lot of
annotations in a short time span you
need to be responsive get some kind of
group chat when they have an example
that they're not sure about let them
post answer immediately so you can iron
out any disagreement that you might have
as soon as possible so you will have the
cleanest data set at the end also it's
good to remember that they they are
seeing a lot of interactions between the
users of your product and your product
and they might have insights or feedback
or something that they see that could be
done better they are a valuable asset of
your project once you have internal
annotators so treat them like valuable
assets share the results you have a
model maybe they annotated thousands of
logs you have 99% accuracy your product
is perfect everyone is happy they are
part of your success and make sure to
make sure to share to share the credit
with them and their results and of
course keep iterating always because
annotators may change they may forget
the guidelines your data may change
maybe you do something different and
people are answering differently to you
so always keep iterating and checking
their gameand ok so this is the second
part how to scale internally we talked a
little bit about having good tooling and
then doing multiple iterations over the
over there the guidelines getting a good
agreement metric both in terms of
performance and in terms of like how its
it's your data and treat people as
people not as CPUs even if their salary
is lower than yours cheat them nicely
because they're part of your success and
they're more important than you in many
cases okay now we will talk a little bit
about unbalanced data so a lot of the
times we have a target class which is
very rare for us so now we will try to
revisit different stages that we had and
see what we should do differently in
order to handle this new situation so
many people ask our chat what are you
about
are you a human that kind of confused
it's not a lot of people let's assume
it's like five percent of the people but
we do want to answer intelligently for
the - these people that we are about
basically and I should expect some
errors not much hopefully and if we will
annotate the data sequentially it will
be very repetitive and very boring it
will be like no no no no no no no yes no
no no and probably you will make
mistakes you will miss some yeses
somewhere in the middle and your your
work will be suboptimal and your
annotation we just waste mortality needs
- in this case we are using active
learning so active learning is the
methodology it's not something that is a
specific mathematical formulation but
the idea is we're using some kind of
model to select the interesting cases
that we want to annotate so instead of
like annotating all of the different
highs and hellos and goodbyes and thank
you that the user says say we will just
annotate the sentences which seems to be
like are you a human or are you about
how we choose this sentence how the
model chooses the sentences can vary so
usually the there is some metric of
uncertainty it might be probability if
you have a probability for a class then
everything around 50% is uncertain and
you want to annotate it maybe it's some
kind of information
gained like the model says well if I
know the label for this example I will
be able to know have a much clearer
boundary for myself so it might be this
information gain but basically some kind
of uncertainty in addition it doesn't
have to be like a machine learning model
you can use for filtering some kind of
like regular expressions or some kind of
like different non ml model to just
filter out the data that that is
interesting for you to annotate in this
case we can use like a regular
expression simple Agora expression of
either the word boat or the word human
appears in the sentence now the classic
approach for active learning is you have
the model inside the loop every time you
annotate an example or annotate a batch
of examples the model updates itself
with the new labor's and then its
uncertainties curves might change and it
will output a new bunch of examples to
annotate so which are the most uncertain
every time in a loop it's a very nice
idea but many times it's not feasible
many time chaining is is slow you can
use offline filtering just use the model
to get the interesting cases and let go
of the uninteresting cases it doesn't
matter how you do this you can do this
filtering or sorting offline but do use
a model in these cases if you don't want
to waste your time and your annotators
time caveat that you have with active
learning is that the annotated data that
you have will be skewed towards some
specific class or specific examples in
our case if you dare Euler expression
all of the sentences will either contain
the word human or the word bot so your
model might have a hard time
generalizing from this data set to the
general distribution of messages for
example that the chat bot sees so
understanding how to train it is one is
one problem which you will not touch
upon but it's a good a good practice to
understand how it affects your accuracy
because if you evaluate your performance
metric let's say accuracy on the SKU
data set it doesn't represent the true
accuracy that you have in the general
population of messages that you get to
the chat bot so this is solution is just
annotated test set sequentially with no
model in the loop and keep this test set
aside for evaluation purposes the more
elaborate solution is to use some kind
of estimation a balanced accuracy score
and you usually need to sample a little
bit of examples from the majority which
the model does not want you to annotate
and then scale it using using inverse
propensity waiting and or something
similar so there are a lot of there is a
lot of literature about this and it
still depends on the situation but do
think about it when you use active
learning so active learning as we said
it enables you to do faster annotations
better annotations using a model in the
loop where they're actively in the loop
online or just differently offline but
you need to be careful about your
evaluation and about your training in
order to do this right now we will move
on and talk a little bit about external
rotation services you might be tempted
to use them because you don't have
internal annotators or we just need more
throughput for your annotations need a
lot of data in a short time span and
there are a lot of options out there so
Mechanical Turk is the probably the most
famous one but there's also figure eight
or Sage maker ground truth which is
based on Mechanical Turk there are a lot
of api's out there which make it easy to
scale out you just create some kind of a
webpage and people are are being paid
like a penny or five cents or whatever
peri notation tasks and you can get a
lot of orientations in a really short
time span however it's very hard to get
good results because
the annotators are very new they don't
know your domain that they change every
day they go online and offline and it's
sometimes really hard to get a clear
clear results from this so I would
suggest you to save this kind of
annotation for simpler tasks something
that you believe everybody can do if you
have a more complex desk like a
transcribing audio it's not suitable in
my view for external taters because it
requires a lot of proficiency if you
have external taters many times it to
change how you present the annotation
task so let's assume I have 20
categories of different answers that
they would like to answer for the user I
have four pages of guidelines I'm not
any external annotate are going to read
four pages of guidelines just not it's
just not worth it they will not do
anything so you need to be creative and
clear and create some other annotation
task which is the proxy to what you
really want to get so an example would
be to show what the user has written
like what is the total price including
Texas and then show them a possible
answer so not the category like payments
or price show them the full answer that
you would like to show the user and ask
them is this answer really good does it
answer is the users query and then using
a lot of annotators you can try to have
some kind of estimation as to what is
the label that you really want you can
also show for example a few different
answers and ask them to choose the best
answer for this specific question but
then you need to think about how you
choose your candidate set you have 20
categories you want you want show 20 lay
20 answers so a lot of a lot of thinking
and a lot of creativity around how you
create your annotation tasks for
external annotators which are
unprofessional
maybe the most important thing about
external rotators they are noisy they
work quickly they need to get things
done they
not always understand the tasks because
they are not part of your domain and
they make a lot of mistakes so you must
use multiple imitators per desk always
never do anything else but there like
the golden rule is useful and take a
majority but this is usually not enough
because let's assume that third of your
answers are incorrect for any reason
then a quarter of your annotations would
be wrong and having a data set where 26%
of the examples are labeled in the wrong
way is a very noisy data set so use more
annotators use kind of overwhelming
majority like six out of seven
annotators or something like this invest
the money to get more and more data
because the data is noisy and having
more of it will enable you to denoise
the signal that you get from the
external annotations also a nice thing
is you can many times check personally
for annotators that have good agreement
rates with other annotators or better
gaming rates and then and then then the
bed annotators and ask to have more time
from the good annotators so it's also a
good practice to use if you are using an
external annotation services so this is
the external annotations it's a
different scenario it might be worth it
worth to try it but you need to adjust
the task be creative and monitor always
without compromising always be very
tuned to what's happening with your data
the key takeaways annotation is not a
one-of it's an iterative process where
you need to go over the guidelines and
or visit your definitions over and over
again
you should be methodological it always
delivers quality there is no other way
to make sure that everything works fine
communicate what you have in your mind
what your task is what your labels mean
do not do not assume that telepathy
works because other peoples would not
understand you and don't reinvent the
wheel even if it's unfamiliar for you
even if you don't never ever use
a validation tool so get familiar with
this and don't invent it that's all you
can get in touch this is my email this
is my LinkedIn if you need a password
like the email from elected this is the
email and thank you very much
[Applause]